is the depression because of bullying or
is it because of the algorithms that
perfectly highlight and curate and and
upvote particular content that causes
drama that causes anger that gets
people's attention and they know if they
say something negative they'll get
people responding to it if they post
something degenerate they're they'll get
more eyeballs and the algorithm will
reward them for this and I think I think
there's an argument to be made here
because you know I grew up in in New
York City I grew up in Brooklyn there
there was bullying on insane levels
there was there was a kid who who you
know one day wasn't coming in for a few
months he was burnt all throughout his
body he lost his father in a fire there
was a bully calling him sausage face
punching him beating him up
psychological abuse where you couldn't
escape it there was gangs there was
people bullying each other to the extent
where you couldn't even go outside in
many instances because you would get you
know kicked in stomped on I got stomped
on a couple times I got I got bullied
like crazy because I didn't even okay so
so I'm saying there always was bullying
yes but but who are you gonna you know
point the finger at to